JP SOUCHAK: Whether you're just
starting out on your journey
toward a career in
Android development,
or you have been
working has an Android
developer for some time,
you might ask yourself,
how can I separate myself from
the pack and get recognized?
Introducing the Associate
Android Developer certification
by Google, an achievement
available to those
who can display the skills of an
entry level Android developer.
The first step on
your journey is
determining if you're
ready to take the exam.
Start by learning
what the exam covers.
Review the skills that
you'll need to demonstrate
when taking the exam.
Next, decide whether
you need training
or are ready to take the exam.
Training is available
online, as well as in person.
Also, training is available in
some colleges and universities.
When you're ready, sign
up and take the exam.
As part of the sign up,
you'll pay an exam fee.
If you live in India,
you'll pay 6,500 rupee.
If you live outside of
India, you'll pay $149.
After you've signed
up and paid the fee,
you will download the exam and
load it into Android Studio
and begin.
The exam's a timed,
performance-based assessment
in which you'll implement
new features and debug
issues in an existing app.
When you start the exam,
you'll have 24 hours to finish.
And once you're done, you'll
submit the exam for grading.
Your submission will be
evaluated through a combination
of machine and human grading.
Based on the outcome
of machine grading,
you'll move on to
the exit interview.
After you've finished, and
you've passed your interview,
you will then receive
a mark from Google
and join our community of Google
Certified Associate Android
developers.
Once you are certified, you can
share your mark on your resume,
LinkedIn, G+, Twitter, and
in your email signature.
[MUSIC PLAYING]